welcome back during the break Nick Kroll
and I were discussing our social media
strategies in this ever-changing digital
world and Nick has a lot of questions so
Nick I have a gift for you
ok time love gifts it's Tyler Oakley
Tyler has a wildly successful YouTube
channel a wildly successful podcast and
is a wildly successful television
personality true and you Meredith this
is a segment that I like to call up to
speed I'm still frozen it was great we
did it
your dial-up is a little slower I will
ask you a series of questions you have
to write your answers uh-huh and then
you will one by one reveal them and we
will see who knows the most internet
slang I'm very excited are you ready yes
yeah beer whiteboards okay I'm genuinely
nervous yeah don't be nervous okay you
might know nothing and that's okay this
is a learning experience for all of us
okay mostly you yes okay okay so what is
a thought a thought it's an acronym I
know I've heard of this and I don't
actually know what it is and it's on my
to-do list to look up yeah it's a do
list of things you need to educate
yourself yeah so grace please reveal
your answer a thought th Oh tea is drunk
for spelling error when googling himself
oh yeah no okay a thought is to have
ordinary uggs have got some clothes it's
actually spelled chot
all right that much I knew you knew that
and it's that hole over there oh that's
it like over there no can I just say I
think we need to have some more email
empowerment but if it's a phrase that
farmers use that hoe over there yeah
okay yeah okay so so far successfully on
success zero points zero points Tyler
next question next question what does
BAE stand for Oh see yes yes thank you
BAE
one by one grace please reveal Bay
before anyone else yeah you look so sad
fiance as eliptical any Beyonce
reference wins appointment it's like you
gotta get on there and get in shape is
an opportunity for Nick to create new
internet jargon
I appreciate that what's the next
question Tyler okay what is shipping
okay what is shipping in internet terms
okay thank you
block your answers in grace please
reveal shipping is when you want two
people to be in a relationship you ship
them nailed it what do we got shipping
is a way to move product baby overlay
what does AF mean locked in grace what
is your answer as something's like
something is like I'm very
temperature-wise warm f first one as
long as these are curse based I'm in
good shape
okay good ready for the next are you
ready for the last question and we're
all tied up
we are we what does thirsty mean
and now lately I guess I'm locked in
Lockton grace what do you have thirsty
it means you are craving the D or the V
big time yeah you're craving the D or
the VAF okay Nick on the board wow you
guys really do know the Internet Wow
like we we do now all of you know the
Internet a lot more than you might have
needed or wanted to so you're welcome I
gotta say I'm pretty parched and I am
thirsty AF we did it well Nick Kroll
thank you so much for being here so make
sure that you guys go check out adult
beginners on April 24th where can they
find it everywhere in the world yeah
adult beginners April 24th theaters
iTunes and VOD all same day and it's me
Rose Byrne and Bobby Cannavale a the
trifecta some might say that some might
say it
some perhaps that it also make sure yeah
you're already getting what you need you
win this as a participant of up to speed
that's yeah
beautiful feel very handsome feel very
empowered when I get out of here you you
look very bay right now thank you you're
welcome
make sure you follow Nick on all of your
social media when we get back
Tyler and I make some bets and drugs
fans can you that's gonna be a great
kiss